scp-682 versus scp-2617  could the icy operatives of the winter  command finally be the ones to take down  the hard to destroy reptile  scp-682 was airlifted into the abandoned  russian village where the 2617 radio  tower was situated and the foundation  fed the tower the reptile's coordinates  as it began attacking the village 2617  generated a large number of deadly ice  warriors who took on scp-682 with both  ferocity and skill destroying 45 percent  of its body mass through sustained  attacks it looked like they might have  the lizard on the ropes until it began  putting out its own radio waves  affecting and disrupting the 2617 radio  tower as well as the researchers in  attendance the affected personnel when  later interviewed were unable to  recognize even the concept of russia